New York Fashion Week has just gotten underway
here in New York City and one of the nation's
hottest young designers won't be taking
part and that reflects Brandon blackwood's
rule-breaking approach to the industry one
that's brought him stunning success just 31
years old he's built a multi-million dollar
company creating handbags with outrageous
resale values and dress is now showing up
on the red carpets of award shows I had
the chance to talk to him about how far
he's come and what's behind his appeal
his Handbags and backpacks seem designed for
an already established clothing line but that
was not the case and for designer Brandon
Blackwood neither was any big plan I would
always say I never want to be a designer
because it just seems super stressful and
like a lot of work and how you feel now I
mean I was kind of right but but I love it
I love this Inca Gold it's really cool the 31
year olds Kendrick trunks we do take a lot of
things for granted they found a feverishly
loyal customer base we're gonna do a tick
tock live that's basically going to show all
the triangles all thanks to social media in
the midst of the pandemic so you guys this
is the bamboo clutch an account he says he
runs all by himself appointment his viral pop
culture moments have struck a chord [Music]
it's so fun and then you see you just want to
move around you and move your hands look at that
a far cry from studying neuroscience at Bard
College on a full ride a winter break spring
break during college I would lie to my parents
and say a science scholarship but I was really at
like nylon magazine in the fashion closet this is
our Elizabeth bag after graduation he worked at a
retail clothing store you know retail was my best
bet to like get as close as I can to the industry
you know that's kind of where my first fashion
relationships began his first design a backpack
I literally went on Google and the throat handbag
manufacturers and I had no plans like starting a
brand or like selling it I just went to make
something for myself I basically lied to this
Factory and I was like yeah I'm starting a line I
just need a sample and but it sounds like a lot of
deception there are a lot of deception it's kind
of crazy so many people would continuously stop me
you know all the others and styles I was meeting
I would show them and they were like oh you need
to sell this like this is great traction but no
access to Capital I had no clue how expensive it
was to start a brand I know like my first order
for my factory was me like six thousand dollars
I didn't realize like the shipping fees the
shipping fees separately like another two thousand
walking into those meetings where you're trying to
grow the business what reaction did you get I was
like mid-20s walking into like Barney's and like
all these stores it was always the same reactions
like how old are you but in the summer of 2020
while the world was in lockdown and enraged by the
murder of George Floyd he stamped his many totes
with the banner in systemic racism everything that
was going on during in 2020 I just didn't feel
like it was right to make a new collection like
it felt really like fake I remember posting
it and I didn't expect the reaction that got
all 500 bags he made sold out instantly then
he took the chance to slide into the DMS of
someone famous who might kick him up to the next
level almost everyone I reach out to with like
now we're gonna stay away from this I damned um
Kim Kardashian and I didn't expect a response
and like 10 minutes later and she's like yes send
it over what do you think it was so controversial
especially at the point of time that you launched
it I think some people generally just did not want
to fight anymore it's not an overnight sensation
he was building up his brand for that exact moment
Naomi elizee is an editor at Vogue for Brandon
basically you can still be exclusive while being
attainable what do you say to that I think it
just shows that there is a market for it it is
about you know being able to be attainable to
these communities that were once excluded from
the conversations of what luxury is in 2022 he
designed the red carpet look for Cheryl Lee Ralph
who took home our first Emmy in
the dress he made just for her
I drop on the floor and just started crying and
I was like we're both Jamaican you know it's
her first win it's like long overdue and she looks
iconic it's my first gown he's gone from backpacks
to bags now clothing what does that say about
his brand it shows that he is growing but also
that he is being intentional and scaling smartly
gorgeous like for a designer who is re-engineering
his take on the fashion industry it's a strategy
that seems to be working how do you explain having
the range of customer that you have affordability
has always been a big deal for you I think we're
allowing you designers messed up is that you
know they'll start these Brands they'll sell
like a blouse for like eight hundred dollars
a thousand dollars and I think that's like the
first like start to like your downfall price your
things for the people that are directly around
you that directly want to see you in and support
you and that's gonna be the pricing that sticks
and in his pricing ranges from like sunglasses
anywhere from a hundred all the way up to you
know other prices but but really but but those
handbags you know two three four hundred dollars
they're way more expensive than that um and he
he caters to so many celebrities and he just
really has caught fire I looked that jacket on you
with the feathers I don't know what that cost but
Mark should get that for you you should get that
for yourself wow and she moves her hands around
yeah yeah he's grown like thirty four
hundred percent it's incredible what
has happened to this gun continued success to him